oui bonjour à tous si vous nous
rejoignez la voie est libre spécial
élections nous votons dans une semaine
pour le premier tour des élections
régionales
et ce matin en direct on débat des
transports une des compétences majeures
des conseils régionaux avec vous eric
sicaud et avec nos invités et voyez avec
françoise branget pour la liste elle est
a u 10 edouard qu'à 20 pour le front
national maxime tvo pour debout la
france
michel neugnot pour la liste du parti
socialiste philippe perdu pour europe
ecologie les verts et j'ai mis deux
roues pour la liste alternative à gauche
alors madame messieurs on l'a entendu
dans les flashs d'information un sondage
est paru ce matin qui place pour la
première fois marie-guite dufay en
position de remporter la région au
deuxième tour et qui place également
pour la première fois le front national
en tête du premier tour edouard
qu'avaient-ils y at il eu un effet
attentat sur votre électorat alors je ne
saurais pas l'évaluer toujours est il
que nous étions réellement dans une
belle dynamique
je rappelle que marine le pen est
considéré comme entête en nord pas de
calais depuis très longtemps c'est le
cas pour marion maréchal-le pen en paca
et la bourgogne franche comté faisait
naturellement partie des régions
gagnables
ça a été dit depuis déjà pas loin d'un
an si on en arrière donc on alors
l'effet attentats je ne sais pas s'il
existe pour nous en tout cas toujours
utile que s'il existe ça n'aura servi
qu'à crédibiliser le discours du front
national dans le sens où ces thématiques
nous les portons depuis très longtemps
ça soit les thématiques de la sécurité
de l'immigration
donc les évidemment les électeurs se
retrouve dans ses thématiques qui sont
aujourd'hui mises à jour avec les
tragiques événements que nous avons
connu michel neugnot donc marie-guite
dufay en capacité de remporter la région
si l'on en croit ce sondage c'est dû à
quoi c'est dû à la campagne où c'est dû
au regain de popularité de l'exécutif
suite à ces attentats
nous avons toujours dit depuis le début
de la campagne match juillet que cette
région était gagnable par la gauche
bon vu les incertitudes de de ce sondage
on est à quatre points près on est
encore dans le navire allait on est dans
la marge d'erreur mais nous nous pensons
que la gauche va gagner ces élections
parce que
parce que là parce qu'elle a un projet
crédible est la seule à avoir vraiment
travailler à un projet et à une logique
un dessin pour la bo gars françoise
branger la droite
enfin votre liste perd 4 points en
quelques semaines suite aux attentats
est ce que selon vous c'est parce que
vos différents ténors n'ont pas été sur
la même longueur d'onde au moment des
attentats et non pas forcément tous
jouer l'union nationale je ne pense pas
les événements dramatiques au début de
l'année avaient renforcé le pouvoir en
place
donc aujourd'hui on est sur un petit peu
le même schéma
alors il est vrai que la campagne des
régionales s'inscrit dans des événements
dramatiques et et auront peut-être un
impact mais il ya encore huit jours et
vous voyez bien que les choses peuvent
changer du jour au lendemain dix avions
la sécurité du président de la
république finalement vous fait du mal
il vient chasser sur vos terres et coûté
une somme dans une politique régionale
je pense qu'il ya des dispositifs qui
ont été pris à paris et six qui sont de
la compétence d'un gouvernement et ceux
qui les mesures qui ont été prises ont
été des bonnes mesures
ceci dit nous sommes dans une élection
régionale avec un bilan régional de la
présidente sortante et ça je ne veux pas
qu'on oublie parce que il y à des
politiques a développé ici qu'ils sont
all également aussi importante
donc les sondages c'est une chose mais
moi je veux pas non plus qu'on fasse le
modem comme arbitre de du deuxième tour
je pense effectivement que nous devons
convaincre encore pendants j'y serai pas
nous sommes et viable j'y mets deux
roues et et philippe hervieu alors vous
êtes tous les deux à vos listes sont à
huit et demi selon ce sondage pour
alternative à gauche et 7% pour les
verts c'est à dire que vous allez la
possibilité de fusionner avec la liste
de marie-guite dufay
ce sera le cas c'est une évidence une
évidence pas encore on n'est pas encore
là pour parler de ça mais ce qu'on peut
observer même si ce sondage
et je suis un petit peu honteux à chaque
fois ces alliances de second tour qu'est
ce qui est sûr c'est que ce qu'on veut
faire c'est battre l'extrême droite et
la droite ça c'est sûr vous pouvez
rejoindre l'émotion l'émotion la honte
on le voit joue aussi face à ce qui
s'est passé face à la barbarie
le rappel des valeurs républicaines
montre que quand la gauche la gauche qui
ne renonce pas rappel ces valeurs on
peut gagner
alors c'est sûr le ps ne gagnera pas
tous seuls elle aura besoin d'autres
sensibilités et notre score au premier
tour le score de l'alternative à gauche
sera permettra la capacité de capacité
de battre la droite et l'extrême avec le
seul objectif c'est de battre le front
national ça on est bien il ya une
spécificité c'est que les jeux ne sont
pas faits tout va se jouer sur la
mobilisation des 10 derniers jours la
gauche et les écologistes peuvent
effectivement emporté cette région le
souhaite en tous les cas et pour
répondre à vote à votre question
évidemment que rien n'est fait les
alliances de second tour on verra le
moment venu mais en ce qui nous concerne
effectivement nous aurons un certain
nombre d'exigences et qu' il faut y aura
pas d'alliance comme ça tout fait et
très convenue on souhaite avoir des d un
accord programmatique sérieux le savez
très bien et pourra se faire qu'à cette
condition là c'est pour ça que je
regrette un petit peu quand seconde que
21 où il ya une mobilisation encore plus
forte sur ces enjeux de du climat qu' il
y ait beaucoup de manifestations qui
étaient supprimées interdite a raison
c'est que j'y vais pour des raisons de
sécurité merci le marché de noël les
manifestations sportives
vous n'aurez pas le temps de conclure si
vous ne vous arrêtez pas là maxime
thibeault oui alors moi ce sondage une
ferries presse que je suis à 5 % en
bourgogne et j'existe pas en france
comptait il ya un tir est donc j'ai
toujours été surpris par ifop
vous savez ifop a quand même pour
directeur de l'opinion le frère monsieur
philippe aux dons je reste très très
méfiants à l'égard de ces sondages avoue
chiffre est aussi attendu à chaque fois
05 ne nous sont pas très générale si je
peux répondre on était à 0,5 pour cent
aux élections européennes une semaine
avant le scrutin nous avons fait 4,5
alors vous faites le rapport on sera
plus de 10%
le soir du premier tour donc bon moi ça
me fait lentement sourires je pense
qu'il ya mieux à faire
cette élection régionale malheureusement
va être éclipsés par monsieur hollande
qui a abusé du temps de deuil et je
trouve ça dommage parce que il a fait un
hommage hier il aurait pu attendre
il aurait pu essayer de remettre la
démocratie parce que la vraie réponse à
la barbarie c'est la démocratie
il aurait pu refaire vivre l'élection
régionale là il va nous cloisonner
ensuite avec la coop 21 à 2 jours de
campagne
c'est scandaleux parce que c'est priver
les français d'un vrai débat
démocratique
mais si on compare très rapidement mais
vraiment très très rapidement des
transports scolaires faut-il qu'ils
soient gratuits dans toute la région
parce qu'il ya des choses un peu
disparate selon les départements
actuellement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous et
réal et 10 15 secondes chacun monsieur
ne nions transports scolaires ou
d'assumer totalement cette compétence
est pas là sous traitées elles rendent
dans la politique de menacer la nar et
des vêtements
pas du tout directement garde de cette
compétence on ne fait pas la loi notre à
l'envers deuxièmement gratuité à terme
parce que ça va se faire progressivement
troisième
man mise en place d'un service public au
niveau de la restauration scolaire et de
l'hébergement avec taris sa série hier
en somme si ces dix ans alors transport
gratuit sur l'ensemble des départements
je rappelle qu'il y en a deux qui ne
sont pas gratuits et puis délégation et
d'étape ou département avec lesquels
nous voulons travailler et nous voulons
nous voulons mutualiser les politiques
pas que sur les trans manif est sur
autre chose
je crois qu'il faut il faut intégrer les
départements dans cette concertation et
les impliquer totalement donc leur
déléguer ses pouvoirs pour le transport
scolaire notamment
effectivement il ya deux départements
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont pas ou le
transport n'est pas gratuit où il faudra
le remettre aux l'appliquait je veux
dire le plus rapidement possible la
carrière du titre gratuit de transport
je vois que c'est bientôt noël
donc nous alors nous on pense qu'il faut
une plate forme numérique 2 me de
mobilité intermodal parce que il faut
pouvoir réserver ses billets par
internet il faut pouvoir avoir le choix
entre scolaire oui oui mais je dis bien
les transports scolaires sont dedans et
par ailleurs nous sommes pour un titre
unique de transport sur l'ensemble sur
l'ensemble des deux régions sur ce la
gratuité des transports scolaires mais
il faudrait aussi qu'on ait des routes
qu'ils soient un peu de meilleure
qualité
hélas entre corbigny et même si c'est
une route départementale la compétence
du conseil départemental qui est
socialiste
donc on commence déjà aussi par
retravailler avec les départements où la
gauche c'est pas d'une démagogie c'est
la réalité c'est la réalité c'est la
réalité de la nièvre monsieur essais
hivernaux
tomas j midori s'il vous plaît justement
l'organisation des transports scolaires
c'est un travail qui doit être fait dans
la dentelle donc oui à la délégation au
département oui à la grande halle à la
gratuité puisque c'est un principe
républicain mais délégation avec un
cahier des charges exigeant en terme de
maintien justement de nombre d'agents et
d'égalité de traitement merci on va vous
laisser 30 secondes chacun pour conclure
je vous demanderais les autres en tout
cas de faire silence on a tiré au sort
avant cette émission et c'est vous
françoise branger qui avait été le
numéro un à vous de paris
à vous d'y inclure en 30e et bien je
dirais que les transports d'ailleurs
comme les infrastructures participe à
l'aménagement du territoire et aussi à
l'attractivité d'une région alors notre
région
et quand même gâtés puisque lll a un
positionnement exceptionnel en europe
nous sommes au coeur de l'europe
et justement nous devons améliorer
toutes les politiques de mobilité
justement pour s'inscrire dans une
dynamique européenne et moi c'est une
vision non grande que je veux partager
avec françois sauvadet edouard qu'avant
vous avez le numéro de votre conclusion
s'il vous plaît alors j'invite les
téléspectateurs et les électeurs de
demain de la semaine prochaine à
apprendre bien en contre cette élection
régionale qui est capital et à ne pas se
laisser abuser par des promesses un peu
farfelues comme cette histoire de canal
etc
sanctionné massivement la gauche qui est
au pouvoir et je crois que c'est
important de le faire et votez pour la
seule liste qui les défend réellement
c'est à dire la liste du front national
et du rassemblement à rennes du soir
rassemblement bleu marine pardon
conduite par ce film ont-elles il me
semble que c'est une occasion historique
de voter perso c'est mental pour vous
philippe hervieu oui le transport c'est
un enjeu crucial pour la nouvelle grande
région parce que nous avons une ré une
région qui est très vaste peu dense avec
une multipolarité d une bipolarité des
capitales et plusieurs petites villes
donc la question des transports et si on
veut renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance à cette région il doit
falloir encore renforcé plus le lait de
transport l'intermodalité
l'intermodalité et les lignes
cependant les choix financiers il faut
faire des choix financiers aujourd'hui
quand j'entends le grand scandale comme
j'entends les aéroports et les terras il
faut faire des choix financer les choix
financiers c'est effectivement
maintenant si possible 30 secondes oui
vous savez si je m'engage à 24 ans c'est
parce que j'ai pas envie à l'âge de mes
parents de vivre dans un pays du
tiers-monde est aujourd'hui depuis
trente ans notre pays a totalement été
abandonné par le ps et l'ump
la région c'est le moment de pouvoir
relancer un peu cette dynamique par
l'économie par le tourisme le transport
naturellement le le ferroviaire est
digne des années 80 c'est une honte
et moi mon objectif c'est d'offrir une
alternative au système politique que
l'on connaît actuellement et aux
extrêmes qui malheureusement nous amène
droit dans le mur
mais chez le menu vous allez prendre
secondes pour conclure la situation at
elle jamais être plate de la
responsabilité et nous appelons
fortement à une forte mobilisation pour
le vote de mon doigt tous les électeurs
de se mobiliser d'aller voter pour faire
face aux actes de barbarie aux aigles de
guerre qu'ils ont connue pour ce qui
concerne pour ce qui concerne notre
programme il est disponible
le voilà sur notre région d' avance et
il ya beaucoup d'éléments que nous n'a
pas pu dire ou bull le débat à cinq est
quand même relativement compliquée qui
se retrouvent dans ce programme lui anti
vigie me et d'euros s'il vous plaît oui
cette émission a montré à l'immensité
des besoins en matière de transport des
besoins à satisfaire
et tout cela ça coûte cher pourtant
c'est essentiel est essentielle pour
pour les salariés pour les étudiants qui
se déplacent quotidiennement essentiel
pour la transition écologique que je
crois qu'on n'a pas assez parlé
aujourd'hui et donc c'est totalement
incompatible avec les politiques
d'austérité qui nous sont aujourd'hui
imposées dire que l'on va développer des
services de transport qu'on va
construire deux nouvelles structures et
infrastructures tout en restant dans le
monde dans les clous des politiques
d'austérité
c'est impossible merci à tous les six
d'avoir participé à ce débat nouveau
débat nouvelle émission cet après-midi
ce sera avec vous eric on se retrouvera
en direct à partir de 15h20 ou par le
rajustement d'environnement de
politiques agricoles et de politique
énergétique c'est donc à 15h20 bon après
midi à tout à l'heure